what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really new
exciting details about not only Kingpin
in the MCU but also Daredevil born again
as well as our first look at Kingpin in
some recent set photos that were
released now if you are not aware
Daredevil born again is currently
filming right now and we've seen many
set photos of Charlie Cox returning to
play the character Matt Murdock and of
course we have seen him also in his
Daredevil suit as well and like I
mentioned today we get our first look at
Kingpin Wilson Fisk now he appeared in
the MCU already in the Hawkeye series if
you did not watch that series I suggest
going back and watching it because you
are going to need to know what happened
in that series to know what's going to
be happening in not just one series but
multiple series because Kingpin is going
to be a reoccurring big bad and yes you
did hear me correctly he is indeed going
to be a big bad and no he's not going to
be on the same level as Thanos or Kang
or Ultron but he is indeed going to be a
big bat and he is going to show up in
several series we saw him in Hawkeye we
are going to see him in the Echo series
and of course he is going to be the
villain and the Daredevil Born Again
Series where we see him face off against
Matt Murdock AKA Daredevil once again
but this time in the MCU so today we
have some details about what to expect
from Wilson Fisk AKA Kingpin in the MCU
as well as some info about a different
side of the MCU a different side that I
think fans are actually going to be very
very excited about and I think this news
is coming at a really good time as fans
could definitely use some really good
exciting news right now so let's go
ahead and start with what Vincent
D'Onofrio the actor who plays Kingpin
said in a recent interview with Newsweek
and the way he started off this
interview is truly something he said
that the show might be different to what
fans of the original series were
expecting in however this series is
going to provide gigantic payoffs in
both the first season and the second
season so right away he has confirmed
there is going to be a daredevil Born
Again season 2. which is huge news but
he actually goes on to say right away
that both Charlie Cox and John Bernthal
who of course plays The Punisher both
play a major part of the show now
obviously Daredevil plays a major part
of the show it's a show about him but we
have learned recently that the Punisher
is going to be returning and now
according to D'Onofrio he is going to be
playing a major role of the show so not
just a quick cameo in an episode or two
but a major role so appearing in
multiple episodes which is great news
because fans are super excited about his
return and perhaps Jessica Jones could
make her return as well that has been
rumored for a while so hopefully fingers
crossed that ends up being true just
like the Punisher returning ends up
being true but D'Onofrio goes on to say
some really really great things in this
interview he says we've only just
started shooting I think we're a couple
weeks in and the show is going to be
very very different than the Netflix
show and it's so exciting because what
we're doing is quite something I think
it's something that people are not going
to expect but always with these Marvel
old comic stories that are being
Revisited and reinvented by us actors
and the writers the main thing is to
answer the fans to give them what they
want but try to be original in some way
at the same time and so that's what
we're doing on the show it's definitely
an original way to look at this and it's
really deep really emotional and by the
second season there are gigantic
gigantic payoffs in the first season too
but I can't say much about that but the
fans are gonna really get what they want
it's really quite cool to be doing it so
right away we have the man himself
Kingpin telling us that this show is
going to be different than what we saw
on net Netflix but it's going to pay off
in gigantic ways on the first season and
the second season and we thank him for
confirming the second season so I know
most people were already super excited
for the show but I am now even more
excited and to address the first look a
lot of people are saying he looks too
skinny he doesn't look big enough he's
no longer wearing the fat suit no longer
has the shoulder pads on and all I can
really say is that I think this might go
a little bit into the plot of the show
and the other shows that he's going to
appear in like the Echo Show because we
do know a little bit about the plot of
Daredevil born again and this could kind
of tie into his character story arc him
being just a little bit Slimmer this is
what we have recently learned about
Kingpin story arc in the new Daredevil
Born Again series coming from The
Insider my time to shine hello and The
Insider website mycosmiccircus.com it is
reported that Wilson Fisk AKA Kingpin is
going to be seeking a political seat in
a few different shows specifically the
mayor seat so in these upcoming shows
Kingpin is going to seek to be the mayor
of New York City which is the perfect
position to be in when you are a Crime
Boss that is a lot of power which is
exactly what Kingpin wants and as I
mentioned before this is going to start
kind of a new genre of the MCU that is
going to be much more mature than
anything that we've really gotten so far
with maybe the exception of werewolf by
night but here's what some insiders have
recently said in response to a tweet
stating that perhaps Daredevil born
again is taking place during the snap in
2020 my time to shine hello said it's
not it's present day MCU with him
running for mayor of NYC giving us one
confirmation of this but then
mycosmiccircus.com released an article
about the same thing but also giving us
more information and based off of what
they said apparently the MCU is starting
its dark rain storyline in their article
they say this according to their sources
the rumors regarding Fisk seeking a
political seat are true however this
plot point will not occur only in one
project and immediately be resolved in
the same project the storyline of Fisk
seeking the mayoral seat of NYC will be
explored in many projects directly while
potentially affecting other projects
indirectly One Source has even specified
that this storyline will mirror elements
from the dark rain storyline from the
comics when asked for clarification it
is implied that the street level stories
of the MCU will be tackling more mature
themes similar to how Netflix approached
the Daredevil and Jessica Jones series
respectively they also specify that
given how the dark rain story arc is one
of The Inspirations for the storyline it
is likely that at some point in time in
Daredevil Born Again Wilson Fisk AKA
Kingpin will succeed and be elected as
the mayor of NYC and I also believe that
this is going to be true as well and
this is awesome to hear because I do
think the MCU needs a little bit more
mature content I think that this is
actually something people really really
really loved about the Daredevil series
on Netflix and even when they announced
that Daredevil was coming to the MCU
getting his own series everybody started
to say it better be the same as the
Netflix series but what they meant was
they hope it's as brutal and as mature
we don't want a watered-down daredevil
we don't want a watered-down Kingpin so
basically they were saying that they
want this to be a mature project they
want it to be violent and it sounds like
that is what we're getting even though
it is going to be different which is
good because different done correctly is
great and according to D'Onofrio it is
going to be quite something to quote him
but here's something that I really
really love about this the Marvel
Netflix shows kind of created their own
tiny little universe that connects kind
of like a tiny little MCU of course you
can never call anything on Netflix the
MCU but the whole Defenders universe
that was all really cool how it
connected and it seems like Marvel
Studios is taking that and putting it in
the MCU in the show we are going to have
the Punisher it's rumored that we are
going to have Jessica Jones as well and
Kingpin is also going to appear in the
Echo series but Daredevil is also
reportedly going to appear in that
series as well so it basically is
showing us that we are going to be
getting a street level story in the MCU
that is going to be a bit more mature
than the other stories that we've seen
so far and in this story with all of the
heroes that we have the big bad of this
street level story is going to be
Kingpin and it's confirmed he's going to
appear in multiple different projects
until he ultimately becomes the mayor of
NYC in which then we might get a little
team up of Heroes trying to take him
down and I want to assume that when all
of these different characters team up
and try to take down Kingpin and his
organization Spider-Man will be one of
those characters Now Kevin feige has
already alluded that we are going to
kind of get different parts of the MCU
the street level Avengers team is one of
them he's already mentioned the street
level several times he's also mentioned
the cosmic side and he's also mentioned
the supernatural side so clearly there
are big plans for for each different
we'll call it kind of sector of the MCU
and right now it sounds like they have
pretty big plans for the street level
side and imagine if we get a team of
characters that consist of Daredevil
Spider-Man possibly She-Hulk Echo Kate
Bishop The Punisher Jessica Jones and we
have that team going up against Kingpin
and possibly even the Sinister Six we
know that Spider-Man is going to get
three more films plus he is also
supposed to get three more team-up films
as well so three solo films and three
team-up films here's the thing we know
what all of them are going to be except
for one of them we have a new Spider-Man
trilogy so those are the solo films and
then of course we have the King Dynasty
in secret Wars what's left is a team up
film well it could be sort of a street
level Avengers team-up film where him
and a bunch of other Heroes take on
Kingpin because Spider-Man right now is
living in New York fighting crime well
if a huge Crime Boss is set up shop in
New York and is about to run for mayor
and eventually becomes mayor that is
definitely going to affect the story of
Spider-Man so I'm thinking that
Spider-Man definitely at some point in
the MC was going to run into Kingpin and
hopefully fingers crossed that's when we
get our Spider-Man interacting with
Daredevil and other characters as well
this could be huge and again based off
of what D'Onofrio said it sounds like
everything is going to be really really
great but hey let us know your thoughts
about all of this in the comments down
below and let us know what you would
like to see please don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on the latest MCU news you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
foreign